It’s one of those sequels that’s been
rumored for years: Goonies 2.
The latest surge of Goonies hype happened
in 2014, when director Richard Donner confirmed
that the long-awaited sequel was indeed going
ahead, but so far… nothing.
Unfortunately for Goonies everywhere, a sequel
becomes increasingly unlikely with every passing
year.
Here's why we never got to see The Goonies
2.
The scripts have sucked
In 2009, Empire magazine conducted an interview
with all of the original Goonies, as well
as director Richard Donner and producer Steven
Spielberg, and naturally, the interview soon
turned to talk of a sequel.
Donner was quick to blame the lack of a decent
screenplay for the film's constant stalling,
telling Empire that he and Spielberg had spent
a lot of energy hunting for a good script,
and that the duo "had many meetings with writers,
but nothing stuck."
Cast member and weird modern vampire Corey
Feldman was more positive about the prospect
of a second Goonies outing, though Donner
didn't share his enthusiasm, stating there
was "no hope" of it going ahead at that stage.
Even Feldman, who doesn’t have much going
on right now except for...whatever this is...knows
that Goonies 2 is a dangerous game to play,
saying,
"It could have a very bad backlash!
At the end of the day, and I have said this
before, the only way a Goonies sequel happens,
and is forgivable to the fanbase, is if it
is done right."
Feldman and co-star Sean Astin even wrote
a sequel themselves and presented it to Richard
Donner, but were told that their ideas were
too expensive.
Considering how much cash goes into blockbusters
today, and the fact that animated prosthetics
and a giant pirate ship weren’t too cost
prohibitive for the original, it’s hard
to imagine what Feldman and Astin turned in
that was deemed too extravagant.
But either way, Astin is game.
“Yes or no: Goonies sequel.”
“Someday.
I hope.”
“You in?”
“If they want me.”
“Alright!”
“Yes!
Yes!
Yes!”
And everyone knows, an angry Al Roker will
not be denied.
“Spielberg!
Get on it!
Make The Goonies 2!”
Producer Frank Marshall has gone on record
as saying that he won't make a sequel just
for the sake of doing it, insisting that the
story has to be right before the film can
go ahead to avoid disappointing fans.
Ironically, fans ended up being disappointed
by another one of his comments…
A reboot instead?
Picture this: a bunch of middle-aged Goonies
have lost touch with what it means to be a
member of the team, leaving their children
to revive their never-say-die attitude and
take them on a new adventure.
It writes itself, right?
Frank Marshall doesn't quite see it that way.
The producer revealed that any new Goonies
project would not actually be a sequel, but
a film made "in the Amblin spirit of Goonies."
So, unfortunately for those hoping for a continuation
of the story, the idea of a complete reboot
has been supported by the writer of the original
movie, Chris Columbus.
Despite previously stating that the only way
the film could be done was with the original
kids as parents, Columbus has since changed
his tune, confirming that he’s currently
on a full nostalgia-attack, and actively involved
in reboots of both The Goonies and Gremlins.
“Look, there are a lot of writers who are
interested in writing Goonies, but the problem
is that we’re very protective because it’s,
it’s a, such a well-loved movie.
The same goes for Gremlins.
Gremlins is a little easier…”
Because that worked out so well for Ghostbusters.
Richard Donner is getting older
As someone who’s keen to see this long-awaited
sequel eventually happen, Feldman has raised
fears that the project is very much time sensitive,
saying,
"Richard Donner is 87 years old.
And it's like, no one really wants to make
it without him.
He's the driving force behind it.
He says it's still alive.
But as we all know, when you get to that age,
things slow down quite a bit.
There is a big possibility that he might not
want to keep driving it."
Feldman went on to explain that Goonies 2
just wouldn't happen without Donner in the
director's chair, adding that every day that
passes without the wheels in motion takes
us a day closer to it never happening.
Chunk out
Even if Goonies 2 is a sequel, they would
have been forced to do it without one of the
most loved of all the Goonies.
[Retching sounds]
Jeff Cohen, the former child actor who played
Chunk, nixed the idea of returning, claiming
that his new career as an entertainment attorney
and author is too good to give up, even if
he does remember his acting days fondly.
“Anybody who says they intentionally give
up acting is lying.
They’re absolutely lying.
Uh, you know, I loved being a kid actor, it
was great, but you know for me I look different,
I was evolving from Chunk to hunk, that I
am today.”
Cohen has become one of the go-to attorneys
in Hollywood, has written a book called The
Dealmaker's Ten Commandments, and the ex-Goonie
also occasionally writes about legal and political
matters for CNBC.
So, he probably doesn’t have enough time
to do the ol’ Truffle Shuffle anymore.
“Ohhhaaaaoohhh.”
Goonies go off-Broadway
Evidently fed up with waiting for a sequel
to be greenlit, Donner went ahead and made
alternate arrangements to bring the Goonies
back to life.
In 2015, the director announced that he was
creating an off-Broadway, immersive production
of The Goonies.
He outlined his vision to Yahoo!
Movies, explaining,
"There's no seats, the venue is you go into
a warehouse and there's something happening
in that warehouse and that's the play you've
come to see, only you become part of it and
you travel through with actors."
The Goonies play has yet to materialize, with
no details to speak of.
Donner was adamant that the show would soon
be a reality, however, and while this would
surely be an unforgettable experience for
any Goonies fan, Donner focusing on this project
means Goonies 2 is as far off now as it's
ever been.
The closest we’ll ever get is a notoriously
weird Nintendo game.
But never say die, right?
“Don’t say that!
Never say that!
Goonies never say die!”
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!